right
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you people thought I forgot about you
but I didn't
you
ah what's happening you bad
[ __ ] I've been missing for a
couple days I've been moving [ __ ]
check out the new dibs we're gonna break
it down for your [ __ ] sometime next
week I just want to touch base with you
and tell you [ __ ] I didn't forget
about you you understand me it's a
beautiful day to be alive the birds are
chirping the [ __ ] the sun's shining
your dick is hard and we're ready to
[ __ ] go you understand me I got three
reef is in the cards Ryan I got two left
still the sour OG I still got this
[ __ ] sensei stop you know the last
three days I've been in the coma I've
been here I've been there we've been
moving [ __ ] couches Lee Steve Simone
my man Burgie I wanna help all you
[ __ ] I wanna thank you for
helping me the [ __ ] out and that's it
it's Friday and if you ain't [ __ ]
sparking with uncle Joey you ain't got
dick it's just that simple
sometimes before the day starts this is
exactly what the [ __ ] you need and I'm
saying you need to [ __ ] warm up the
people and get people excited about so
we can me I don't give a [ __ ] it's just
another weekend
all these [ __ ] Gentiles are jumping
up and down doing this and doing that
I'm gonna get the [ __ ] office
together I'm gonna get my life together
I'm gonna get my wardrobe in order and
it's all [ __ ] over you understand me
October 15th it's just a [ __ ] jump
away I'll be ready for you [ __ ]
I'll make you proud of me and I'm saying
I'm not gonna shoot a special and be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna shoot a
special for you guys to say that's my
uncle [ __ ] Joe we're here I
[ __ ] put it together and look at
them look at them now shooting
specialization bitch-slapping
[ __ ] smoking reefer
who gives a [ __ ] anymore you understand
me
we're here we're [ __ ] queer uncle
Joey
don't really did one episode this week
it's Labor Day [ __ ] it we did what we
had to do we'll be back Sunday you guys
will wake up Monday for Labor Day and
bam there'll be a [ __ ] podcast there
and that's it man we got a great weekend
next Thursday I'm a [ __ ] flappers and
next Friday and Saturday I'm at the
Melrose improv eight o'clock show and
then guess what
I'm an Austin [ __ ] Texas then I
got up in New York City it's the best
month of my [ __ ] life you understand
me
who goes to [ __ ] in New York and taxes
all in [ __ ] ten days uncle Joey does
[ __ ]
oh my god it's gonna be a great day look
at the Sun you could feel the love from
God on your face you know I'm saying and
I said that's it that's that I'm a
little [ __ ] stoned
I'm sorry I've been missing for a few
days taking care of other [ __ ]
personal obligations but when I'm back
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] back [ __ ] you guys
know that I know that so I'm not worried
about I didn't want you to think that I
forgot about you [ __ ] because
without you [ __ ] I got who else
I got [ __ ] dick I got nothing you
understand me
by that burn method a method adieu halt
and company [ __ ] I love it I
love Fridays
you know why this cuz it's over let's
fill up with some [ __ ] sensei no I
really see the debt will see that the
sour OG is an indica hybrid which
they're always pretty good to sourwood
jeezum they got a little indicate man
but the [ __ ] sensei star this you're
getting karate chops to the [ __ ] neck
it's one thing hearing people yelling
and screaming when you're high but to
sit there and just get karate chops
every 10 minutes that's a complete
different type of weed and that's the
way we're gonna bust that right now you
understand and as usual the under-18
hang up now I don't need you aggravation
in my [ __ ] life over that home
reading High Times uncle Joey I need a
star you need a [ __ ] note book
[ __ ]
go back to school you're too young to be
doing this [ __ ] I started doing this
[ __ ] but that was a [ __ ] kid if we're
to get me got me nothing you don't get
high too old then you until you decide
what the [ __ ] you really want to do you
don't say if not you're gonna be in the
school all confused and [ __ ] you don't
know whether yeah I feel like a woman no
you're not you're a [ __ ] man not at
all
smoke some more weed or three more
bodies
and now I know but I always loved you
but my heart sorry that [ __ ] hit took
me deep deep deep deep into the murky
waters of the [ __ ] underworld
[ __ ] so anyway that's it and that's
that now you're off till four seven
Monday morning we're gonna do with your
life you're gonna sit there like a
[ __ ] if you hear this tool in your
mind that that that that that that that
if you hear that when you're walking
down the street you [ __ ] up it's time
to smoke weed that means you got too
many things on your mind that's what ADP
really is when you're here that if
you're walking down the street new you
know if that's the soundtrack to your
[ __ ] life it's over it's over
[ __ ] yeah get your life together
you understand you gotta be hearing like
Zeppelin your - Sabbath and [ __ ]
Pantera [ __ ] like that
but I see some of your [ __ ]
with that look on your face make
something's going on in there it's time
to [ __ ] get smoked it's time to get
stoned you understand me
I'm over here drool repeating my words
it's [ __ ] 9:30 in the morning who's
better than us
gettin [ __ ] stoned Kelly good
anyway I gotta take two steps to the
real and get out hey I'm stoned to the
gills
I got jujitsu today I got a couple
[ __ ] meetings and that's it I got do
some spots tonight the ice house but
beside that that's it [ __ ] uncle
Joey's here with you all day long
check-in I'm gonna put some music up put
some dates up and [ __ ] put some links up
and that's it we're all here all right
have a great day have a great [ __ ]
weekend with your family stay safe stay
away from Isis those [ __ ] gonna
be lurking this weekend of parades [ __ ]
you always got look for them though shop
the barbecues - my sister show up to
barbecues and the wheat your [ __ ]
shish kebabs and they'll shoot you in
the [ __ ] head you need that
aggravation in your life [ __ ] no mind
your business stay black and keep
smoking that weed and keep doing 22
push-ups in there right I love you talk
suckers with all my heart the church
will be back Sunday night by the time
you wake up Monday morning boom we'll be
right [ __ ] there for you right you
know why cuz I love you [ __ ]
who else tells you that that they love
you I'll start the day off and I love
you everything else is [ __ ]
background music these people you have
to think negative we have to think
positively
we got tell of the [ __ ] that I
love you [ __ ] I'm saying them
right away the word love triggers into
your mind but it seats and T is so one
night you know what the [ __ ] you gotta
do I don't know about this I wake up one
of the stab a [ __ ] everyone but
you say a cup over I loves you and
things even though all right that's the
lesson of the [ __ ] day today
stay black be careful don't take no
cosby pills and that's it uncle Joey
loves UCF lapis or Melrose improv mix
the Friday and Sam I stay black